you know if you had asked me just a few
years back if I would end up becoming
one of the strongest voices in America
defending skinny jeans wearing
Millennials I would have been shocked
but I got to tell you I'm about sick of
the press picking on these Millennials I
have got and I know some of you people
you know it's like it's like people
picking on teenagers all the time you
know and I know Millennials aren't
teenagers I'm not saying that but they
just pick out a group of people and they
say okay these Millennials are all
entitled none of them work you know they
all live in their mother's basement and
there's a percentage that do stuff like
that but I gotta tell you I work with a
lot of Millennials I've got an office
full of them well I guess 602 some
people working here and probably the
average age and the place is that 30 or
below I got a ton of these tech
developers and creatives and marketers
and I as an employer I find the
millennial generation to be one of the
best and easiest to hire out of because
when you're interviewing there's only
two kinds they're awesome where they
suck and they come in and they go I'm
worthless I don't want to work I want
you to give me everything and you can
tell it they'll tell you that in the
interview and of course we don't hire
them or they come in and they go just
give me a cause I'll do anything to win
I figure helping people we will but they
they are such a cause driven generation
and and they're not all irresponsible
and not all ridiculous and not all and
really I don't even I don't know what
the percentages are but and maybe I'm
just exposed to so many good ones but
this I don't think that half of this
generation I got to tell you I think the
bay I'm a baby boomer and I think the
baby boomers were a much worse
generation in a lot of ways they were
worse with money
Millennials are even the irresponsible
ones at least know what they want to do
with their money and they do it on
purpose
sometimes it's stupid but they're at
least doing it on purpose
and so I've gotten where I resent these
articles two or three people sent me
this this week maybe four or five people
sent me this week some of them friends
just emailed me today if you got to see
this market watch calm Millennials want
luxury sheets exercise bikes and Music
Festival tickets but they don't always
have enough cash or a desire to put them
on a credit card so they're turning to
an even more expensive method of payment
financing in recent years like credit
cards aren't financing how stupid are
you market watch in recent years payment
companies including PayPal a firm and
bread have created installment plans for
retailers that give consumers the option
to finance the weirdest purchases over
time now let me just tell you I've been
doing this show 25 years when I started
this show there were no credit cards
accepted in grocery stores and no fast
food places accepted credit cards to me
when you started being able to buy a
whopper on a piece of plastic or finance
your beer on a credit card at the Publix
to me that was a weird purchase I don't
know why I don't think music festival to
festivals ikut SAR any different or
exercise bike tickets or buying an
exercise bike seemed different
just put that on the credit card what's
different it's stupid is cried but I
mean why is that a uniquely millennial
disease these payment methods have taken
hold at a time when Millennials have
been more reluctant than their parents
to use credit cards Millennials had
about two credit cards each on average
last year according to credit reporting
company Experian which is God in a box
apparently that's compared with about
three or four three for boomers and an
average of two and a half for Generation
X and now they don't have to wait to be
able to afford that Vitamix blender I
have a Vitamix blender I resent that
what could go wrong quite a lot consumer
advocates say they come
Brook linen sells pricey sheets its
classic sheet set sells for queen-size
beds costs 200 $29 but that can be steep
for millenials well duh
could be steep for a lot of people this
is just this is just a crappy article
market watch you just drop the ball
you're trying to say that Millennials
are using bad methods of financing to
buy sheets and Vitamix and exercise
bikes and music festival tickets like
this is a new human disease that's
unique to Millennials every generation
has bought stupid stuff they couldn't
afford and borrowed money to do it in
stupid ways it's not a millennial
disease it's a stupid people disease and
they're stupid people in every
generation there's nothing evil about a
Vitamix there's nothing evil about music
festival tickets and there's nothing
evil about $129 sheets
that's just ridiculous what's stupid is
when people that are broke by this kind
of stuff Vitamix blender I call one the
other day is like four hundred and some
dollars
my wife she puts everything in that
thing it's gross the stuff she puts in
there but um
looks like toxic waste when she gets it
blended up it's like it's like a whole
meal in there and it shouldn't be
blended together that should only happen
in your stomach you know but she does
this toxic waste but it's it requires an
expensive blender to do this but I've
got the money to buy $400 blender if
you're broke and you're 54 or you're 24
you shouldn't buy a Vitamix so for it's
the freakin Bentley of blenders really
you shouldn't buy that so what what's
new why is this a millennial it's not a
millennial thing Market Watch you
screwed up and you're dissing these
people and at the tone I'd use you
snotty with your glasses down on the end
of your financial nose wagging your
finger at a younger generation like
you've got your crap together and you
don't you're still paying on your
student loan while you're writing this
article from journalism school and and
thumbing your nose and other people this
is just wrong it's just wrong
listen if you're a millennial or if
you're not and you don't have $129 in
cash you should not buy $129 sheets
hello why was that hard that's not hard
but this is not a millennial disease I
mean you don't have to have a long beard
and skinny jeans to do stupid stuff it's
not required lots of people do stupid
stuff they don't look near that cool you
know you don't have to have random
tattoos to do stupid stuff lots of
people don't have random tattoos that do
lots of stupid stuff you don't have to
have name it whatever you don't have to
be bald and old and fat to do it you
know it's it's it's a human disease to
buy stuff in America that you can't
afford with money you don't have to
impress people you don't really like and
so I'm sorry I'm not jumping on the we
hate Millennials bandwagon and I don't
know how I ended up being the one
speaking out on behalf of Millennials
but I guess I am that's the strangest
mix of things you could ever think of
right there but I guess cuz I got a lot
of them around me that are awesome I
guess that's it including my own kids so
shut up seriously this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]